- So I was raised in a bit
of a conservative family
where women shouldn't be climbing
and traveling on their own.
So coming to Dubai really
helped me find all these sports
that I enjoy doing.
(dramatic instrumental music)
You have to reconnect to
nature, to Mother Earth
to feel better about yourself.
(dramatic music)
- My name is Mark Beaumont
and I'm an endurance athlete.
With the current world record
for cycling around the planet.
Seeking adventures and finding stories is
what I'm most passionate about.
Ever since I can remember,
I've had that sense of
curiosity about the world.
This time I've come to Dubai.
(dramatic instrumental music)
Here I'm meeting Ghida,
to hear how her love of the
outdoors and adventure sports
has hugely helped her,
both physically and mentally.
(dramatic instrumental music)
What have you got planned?
What do think we can
get up to in the next?
- So, I'm gonna take you wakeboarding and
we're gonna go to Hatta.
We're gonna kayak in a dam.
And we're gonna hike a
little bit and maybe camp.
- And is that still in
the desert or is that
a completely different terrain?
- It's a completely different terrain.
- Amazing.
(upbeat music)
- [Guida] Be careful.
- It's not often I try something
that I've never done before.
- Really?
- Wakeboarding's not big in Scotland.
Maybe 'cause it's too cold.
- So Mark, when the boat starts moving,
you feel it and you just glide with it.
And then you just look
at the boat and enjoy.
I've always been active in Dubai,
but then I had an
incident where I fractured
my hip and I couldn't
do anything for a year.
And this was the turning point for me.
This is what made me become
a more adventurous person.
I thought that I have to try everything,
I couldn't do in that year.
And this is where my journey started.
- Ah, that doesn't look too easy.
(laughing)
Pretty amazing place to go
wakeboarding for the first time.
What a backdrop!
Ooh wee!
- The water is nice!
You can do it!
Yeah!
Stand up!
Woo-hoo!
(dramatic music)
He's a natural!
He's doing really great
for the first time.
(dramatic music)
- That was incredible!
- [Guida] So good! You
are a natural! (laughs)
- I loved it.
That is incredible.
My arms!
- [Guida] Yeah.
- My arms hurt.
- [Guida Voiceover] I really think
that being healthy
physically is very important
but I really focus on being
healthy mentally more.
Anytime I feel down or
I feel super anxious,
I just pack my bags and
travel to the mountains
or go camping or just
be in the outdoors and
reconnect with myself.
Thank you!
As someone who suffers from anxiety,
being outdoors and being
active help me so much
and it still does.
- [Mark] I mean you feel
like you're a million miles
from Dubai here.
- [Ghida] I know.
- [Mark] Skyscrapers to mountains.
- [Ghida] To natural skyscrapers!
- [Mark Voiceover] I think
what sport's given you know
is the fact that you're not
worrying about tomorrow.
You're not thinking too
much about the past.
You're absolutely stuck in
that moment and she's like
passionate about sharing that journey.
(dramatic instrumental music)
It gets dark pretty quickly.
- [Ghida] It's nice.
- [Mark] And this looks
tiny from the valley floor.
- [Ghida] Yes!
- Look at it!
- Wow!
- Top of the world.
Nice view.
Adventure sports and
finding them is ultimately
from our time together that's
kind of created your identity.
It's kind of who you are.
- I know that my aim is to
get more and more people
in the outdoors.
Like this is something I want to do.
Being active and being closer
to nature will make you
a better person mentally and physically.
- I've absolutely loved this.
And do you know what the coolest part?
You know, you've been so
honest about your journey.
You know what all these
adventures have done for you.
So thank you.
And I hope we can do some more.
- [Ghida] It's my pleasure.
(dramatic music)